die hitze lässt auch das eis in den
bergen schmelzen und die gletscher geben
dadurch geheimnis preis der stock die
gletscher im matterhorn gebiet zum
beispiel hat jetzt ein menschliches
skelett freigegeben und nun wird
spekuliert handelt es sich um den
verschollenen tengelmann erben karl
erivan haub der dort vor über vier
jahren verschollen ist
überall auf der welt schmelzen die
gletscher die ice gibt immer mehr
gruselige geheimnisse preis ein
bergsteiger machte jetzt in den alpen
einen grausigen fund am stock die
gletscher fand der mann menschliche
überreste dann eine unglaubliche meldung
es könnte sich um den 2018 spurlos
verschwundenen chef der tengelmann
gruppe handeln um den deutschen
milliardär karl erivan haub
er war am 17 april 2018 bei einer
bergtour am kleinen matterhorn im
schweizerischen zermatt unter
mysteriösen umständen spurlos
verschwunden wurde später für tot
erklärt seine leiche bislang verschollen
doch ist tauchen zweifel auf ob es sich
bei der mumifizierten leiche wirklich um
den deutschen manager handelt der
klimawandel
er sorgt dafür dass das eis der
gletscher seine grausigen geheimnisse
preisgibt vor wenigen tagen ebenfalls in
den alpen im eis des aletschgletschers
dieser unglaubliche fund
ein flugzeug die maschine vom typ piper
cherokee stürzte 1968 am alex fletcher
ab drei menschen ein lehrer ein chefarzt
und dessen sohn starben bei dem unglück
durch das schmelzen des eises kam die
maschine jetzt wieder zum vorschein
im juni diese meldung 52 jahre nach dem
tragischen unglück tauchte im himalaya
der zweite show des verschollenen
bruders von reinhold messner auf 2004
waren die überreste von günther messner
in 4300 metern höhe entdeckt worden
müssen wir wegen des klimawandels jetzt
mit immer neuen funden rechnen
wir haben in den alpen eine lokale
erwärmung
diese erwärmung läuft schneller ab als
die durchschnittliche globale erwärmung
das sorgt für sehr viel schmelzwasser
märkte vor models alle modelle zeigen
dass das eisvolumen in den berggebieten
in den algen dramatisch abnimmt
das volumen des gletschers es geht immer
weiter zurück
in den alpen werden noch zahlreiche
bergsteiger vermisst ihre überreste
könnten jetzt zum vorschein kommen
eine frage der zeit bis das eis sein
nächstes geheimnis preisgibt
[Musik]
ja und dort am matterhorn in zermatt ist
unser reporter jörg volkening york wie
wahrscheinlich ist es dass die gefundene
leiche tatsächlich karl erivan haub ist
ich habe jetzt heute nochmals mit der
kantonspolizei wallis gesprochen
eine identifikation steht weiter aus so
lange kann man also auch sich nicht an
den spekulationen beteiligen er diese
leiche ist also so lange steht auch
weiter der verdacht im raum dass ist
doch damit hat er sein könnte es gibt
aber doch ein paar fakten die zeigen
dass es wohl eine andere person ist man
weiß von dem bergsteiger der die leiche
ende juli gefunden hat dass diese person
neonfarbene skibekleidung eine jeans an
hatte alles etwas altmodischer ein stil
der 80er jahre er hatte auch einen
skistock der marke maxi dabei das war
eine innovation aus dem jahr 1974 und
dieser mann war auch nicht so gekleidet
wie ein wirklich gut ausgerüstet das
skisportler und man war jetzt erfolg
er wollte an der patria glacier
teilnehmer wein trainierter sportler er
wusste schon wie er sich hätte für den
bergwerk festmachen können also das
deutet doch darauf hin
dass ist nicht karl erivan haub ist er
da auf dem gletscher gefunden wurde
warum dauert die identifizierung so
lange
auch dazu hat mir arterien bellwald von
der kantonspolizei gesagt das ist bei
älteren knochen im bereich etwas länger
dauert die dna zu extrahieren und dazu
kommt dass man natürlich nicht von allen
vermissten die dna eingelagert hat
jetzt
drei personen die in betracht auch autos
und vergleichsproben bitten ob die nach
so langer zeit überhaupt noch vorhanden
sind ist dann die frage und so lange
liegt die leiche jetzt einfach in der
gerichtsmedizin in der kantonshauptstadt
zieren
die sterblichen diesem hingebracht wurde
und so lange warten darf erreicht
angehörige jetzt sehnsüchtig auf die
erlösende nachricht ja jörg der ton ist
ein bisschen schwierig wegen der leitung
aber letzte frage doch noch kurz wie
viele menschen werden in der region denn
eigentlich noch so vermisst
es sind dem ganzen kanton wallis 300
personen und allein rund um das
smartphone sind es 40 leute tom ist
werden und durch diesen klimawandel
tauchen jetzt quasi fast im wochentakt
personen auf erst vor wenigen tagen bei
saas fee auf einem gletscher wiederum
dort nur noch knochen und vor fünf
jahren tauchte da sogar dass die
genossen die skelette von einem seit 75
jahren vermissten ehepaar wieder auf
also da werden wohl noch einige
geheimnisse gelüftet
die folgerung aus zermatt vielen dank
dorthin
[Musik]